épidémie de coronavirus ou pas à 8
heures il faut nourrir les bêtes
le tractopelle entame alors son ballet
quotidien pour alimenter les vaches
d'alice mais depuis quinze jours
aucune vache n'a été vendu à l'abattoir
les tarifs de la viande au kilo sont
bien trop bas moi ça me coûte 4 euros 4
euros 70 à produire je vends 3 euros
soit sinon il me manque un euro du kilo
alors ça c'est pas très parlant pour un
pour quelqu'un de lambda sauf que 1 euro
du kilo sur une bête qui en fait 500 ça
fait 500 euros par bête ne pas toucher
ses 500 euros ou l'égard des quinze
jours de plus à la ferme pour un coût de
revient d'environ 30 euros
le calcul est vite fait alors pour faire
pression sur les circuits de
distribution et d'abattage et l'a décidé
de ne plus envoyer ces animaux en
boucherie faute de revenus suffisants
ils mangent en général pour un euro
cinquante par jour
je les achète 1000 euros je les revends
non 500 ils sont restés 240 jours eh
bien voyez faites vous même le calcul
grand chose avec ça il faut donc que je
paye l'ouvrier
même le matériel les assurances les
prêts ça va pas me coûter très cher de
les garder quinze jours à trois semaines
de plus clairement c'est du vivant
il ya un moment je serai obligé de les
vendre mais a gardé ses bêtes trop
longtemps elle risque aussi de perdre de
l'argent
l'agricultrice est donc prise en
tenaille
selon elle la dernière fois qu'elle a
dégagé un bénéfice grâce à son élevage
c'était il ya huit ans